welcome to the David Pakman show I am
fairing cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today
busy busy news weekend so let's jump
right into it one of the biggest stories
that came up within the last 48 hours
was the story about deutsche bank the
New York Times reported that five
current and former employees at Deutsche
Bank had flagged numerous transactions
in both Donald Trump's accounts and
Jared Kushner's accounts because they
believed that those transactions may
have been illegal so here's what we know
from those five former and current
Deutsche Bank employees most of whom by
the way remain nameless anonymous
sources because they still want to work
in the industry but what they did is
they have a computer program set up to
identify any kind of transactions that
seemed suspicious
once that computer program Flags these
transactions as suspicious those then go
to what they call mid-level employees
who review them and if they feel that
there might be any illegal activity
taking place within those transactions
they then create a report they send that
report to higher up management folks and
those folks then send it along to the
Treasury Department for a full
investigation in these particular
instances and the transactions involving
vote both Donald Trump and Jared Kushner
these employees the mid-level ones who
manually reviewed it did think that
there could be potential criminal
activity taking place they made their
reports sent it to the higher-ups and
just waited on that information to go to
the Treasury Department except that it
never went to the Treasury Department
and that's the problem
those high-ranking managers at Deutsche
Bank decided not to pursue it they
thought no these mid-level employees
they're just kind of over blowing this
let's not worry about the potential
money-laundering that they think they
may have uncovered with Donald J Trump
and Jared Kushner another
reason why this story is so important is
because these transactions were taking
place in 2016 when Donald Trump was
running for president and 2017 when
Donald Trump was president and Jared
Kushner was a senior White House adviser
for some reason so these were happening
while the man was president of the
United States they were happening while
the man was running to be President of
the United States the people at the bank
at least the ones who really looked at
it said hold up something's not right
here what we're seeing and this is
according to the report is lots of money
that's bouncing back and forth between
accounts and at least one of those
accounts was with the now-defunct Trump
Foundation and that's how they described
it just money moving back and forth back
and forth very very suspiciously same
thing with Kushner and Kushner's
accounts were actually with wealthy
Russians so once again it always ends up
coming back to Russians somehow or
another but that's who Jared Kushner's
accounts were bouncing money back and
forth between Deutsche Bank in the past
in fact past couple years was popped for
forty billion dollars for laundering
money for wealthy Russians now I know
some people get annoyed say uh enough
with the Russians okay but that's a
thing that happened that that's
verifiable we know Deutsche Bank helped
launder money for the Russians that's a
fact accept it and move on the other
thing we know is that Deutsche Bank also
allowed money to flow in and out of Iran
even though we have sanctions in place
that would prevent such transactions
from taking place
so Deutsche Bank doing business where
they're all not allowed to do business
do each bank doing illegal business over
in Russia and and I can't stress this
one enough Deutsche Bank several years
ago was also fined by the Treasury
Department because they didn't follow
the protocols that had been put in place
that the bank was supposed to follow to
identify potential money launderer
so basically Deutsche Bank is the bank
to go to if you want to launder money
here's another piece of the puzzle here
you have a woman by the name of Tammy
McFadden one of the few people in this
story who was willing to be named Miss
McFadden was fired from Deutsche Bank
about a year ago after she brought it to
the attention of management at the bank
that they weren't still weren't by the
way following those money laundering
protocols to identify potentially
suspicious transactions she was fired
for that she also happens to be one of
the people who personally saw the
transactions and reviewed them for both
Donald Trump and Jared Kushner so here's
what needs to happen right now it's
perfectly possible that none of this was
illegal it's highly unlikely that none
of this was illegal so miss McFadden who
has seen this information probably needs
to pay Congress a little visit
I hope members of Congress saw this
report come out on Sunday it said you
know who would be a great person to
subpoena
Tammy McFadden you know who probably has
a lot of information that we need for
the investigations we're carrying out
Terry McFadden so do you know who we're
going to send a special invite to Terry
McFadden Tammy McFadden scuse me
but that's what needs to happen folks
right now Congress is supposed to be
working with Deutsche Bank they were
working with Deutsche Bank to get Donald
Trump's financial records until the
Trump family sued them to prevent
turning over that information a lawsuit
that is most likely going to fail on its
merits just because the president cannot
interfere with the work of Congress
they're trying to argue in court that
the reason Democrats are doing this is
only for political reasons and because
it's not related to legislation they
shouldn't have access to this
information unfortunately our system of
checks and balances does allow Congress
to carry out investigations and
therefore the courts are basically going
to be powerless to stop the Democrats in
their investigate
but in addition to the records I do
believe that miss McFadden needs to come
and tell Congress what she knows what
she saw and if they can convince the
other folks who were nameless in this
article because they still want to work
in the industry they said they need to
come forward as well because I don't
think this would necessarily hurt your
chances of working in the finance
industry if you come forward and say hey
my boss is committing crimes I know it
does and I know that's how you know
people attack whistleblowers but these
are people that need to be hoisted upon
our shoulders right I mean regardless of
who it's about it could be about anybody
in this country not Trump or Kushner if
they're exposing financial crimes that
is heroic they know what they're risking
and that's why most of the people in
this story chose to remain anonymous
because they don't want to be retaliated
against they don't want to be
blackballed from the financial community
but they also want banks to stop
breaking the law and that is clearly
what we've seen over the years take
place with Deutsche Bank and I don't
think it's a coincidence that Deutsche
Bank was one of the only banks willing
to loan money to Donald Trump that's
another piece of this puzzle you know
they gave him two and a half billion
dollars at a time when nobody else would
lend this man any money
we know that Deutsche Bank has a history
of helping money launderers something
doesn't add up here right and that's
what Congress is trying to find out we
have learned too much damning new
information about Deutsche Bank to let
this hitch issue slide maybe there's
collusion there probably not you know
that could all be coincidental but
things like money laundering bank fraud
wire fraud tax evasion yeah I think
those are crimes that Congress
definitely needs to uncover if they
exist